Albert Breer senior writer for the mmq
be Albert I know you're down at the
Cuyler Murray Invitational better known
as the NFL Combine but is there is he'd
like the biggest story that you've seen
down there Albert in the last couple
years in terms of kind of the hype
machine I feel like he's the only name
we know almost in his draft
well maybe outside of the scene late
last year he nice I don't know it's a
pretty good run so I can I say the part
of the whole thing you know first year
covering oh yeah covered thankfully the
pack at the New England right behind Tom
Brady in 2005 and I got to be around
Doug a bunch and I remember like I just
got the distinct sense having been
around him but he never thought that it
was really his fault that he can't
didn't become a star he just felt like I
because I'm 5 foot 9 I never got the
opportunity if I got the opportunity I
would have become a franchise
quarterback and then how many other guys
are there they're just like that right
like that they thought that it was great
5 foot nine 5 foot 10 5 foot 11 college
quarterbacks and so maybe the most
interesting thing about this whole thing
to me is you know now we're sort of
gonna get to find out because something
is gonna connect to him and something
there's gonna go all in on a guy who's 5
9 saipan that in that ring and so that
part of its interesting obviously you
get the basketball part of it that's
interesting it's just like I said like I
thought they can may feel was about it
fascinating prospect easy to possibly
get when he came out last year and it's
just amazing to think now that his back
up last year might be trumping him a
year later you know Albert I still keep
telling people that 5 9 and whether it
was 7/8 and 510 and an eighth that to me
is a big difference seeing that 510
to me is a little more tonight ok
acceptable because you do have the car
right now in the league with a Russell
Wilson is that what you're hearing out
there as well that the 510 now is like
okay we can breathe a sigh of relief
because I think it's more acceptable
because of there is a kind of a
comparison to Russell Wilson yeah you
know what I think that coming in here
the teams are probably a little bit more
interested in his weight to be honest
with you okay
yeah versus 510 I think from an optics
standpoint it does make a difference you
know and I'm sure I'm sure quietly you
know he's not gonna show it I'm sure
he's like you know mentally doing a
point when he came in at over 510 but I
really think what seems were more
concerns that was assault and his
ability to carry weight and so I think
coming in at 2:07 was actually probably
more important than coming in over 510
and reason why at least on a perception
standpoint there's a feeling you're
gonna have to play in a certain way get
the most out of them you have to move
them around a little bit to get the most
out and you have to take advantage of
his athleticism beautiful hallstatt of
them and if you're doing that the
catch-22 is well he's gonna have to take
it and then the question becomes does he
have the frame to hold up in the NFL and
take those hits and get an open question
because playing behind a great offensive
line last year at Oklahoma against some
pretty mediocre defenses in the big 12
it didn't get hit a lot
and so that's why I think you know now
getting into an NFL nutrition program
and an assault strength and conditioning
program he's going to be able to play at
205 210 versus you know 185 190 wherever
he was and he was Oklahoma and I think
being able to put on that way in advance
of the combine is a good first step to
proving he's gonna be able to do that
you can follow him on Twitter great
follow by the way at Albert Brewer on
Twitter senior writer for the mmq b and
in Albert my next question is this since
calimary won't be throwing at the
combine obviously he's going to have a
pro day that pro day is on march 13th
that's also the Lea year starts for the
NFL so now to me
sigh some teams will kind of be showing
their hand by showing up at this
Oklahoma pro day instead of being in the
office on the first date and now you can
sign free agents is that a kind of you
got to delegate some guys to go there or
does general managers say you know what
I'll be here that other guys do handled
it all the business it's an interesting
way of looking at it definitely right I
think it's not so much who's gonna be
there cuz Oklahoma I'm always gonna have
someone there it's who's making the trip
right i'ma cook Kingsbury and the arm
shows up well yeah I mean then a lot of
money too if they're all showing up and
forth yeah you're paying attention to
that it mike Mayock and Jon Gruden are
there you're paying attention to that so
I don't think it's so much would show up
I think it's who is selling up from
those fees and certainly if you see an
owner you see em or you see a head coach
there I think it's fair to say that it's
probably not you're probably not there
to go and look at Cody for you know what
I mean the owner there you probably well
the one thing I could tell you this is
that there's been some awkward moments
over the last couple of days last night
I'm watching a USC and UCLA basketball
game right and they show a picture of
Josh Rosen who was at the game yesterday
and in the back of my mind is like I'm
not thinking of Josh Rosen the starting
quarterback of the Arizona Cardinals I'm
thinking of Josh Rosen possibly on the
move at some point because of his
general manager Steve Connick you
mentioned not being fully committal I
should say and those thoughts so what's
going on with this Josh Rosen dynamic
and is there a possibility that he could
possibly move to a team that you used to
cover in the Patriots I think you're
thinking the right way now I don't mean
they're gonna do yet right I won't say
they're you know they took a big swing
to go and get Kliff Kingsbury right
right unconventional move and if you're
gonna do something like that you gotta
be honest guy and if flip things where
it comes to you and your seat Connery
and I feel good well
calimary the perfect for back pain oh
you know I think it's hard not to take
right because the position is too
important and if he thinks that collars
the right guys and I think you have to
you have to give me coach that if they
could get to that point and I still you
know big if I think what's so
interesting where Rossum could go that
there are so many teams that are they
having a long-term answer at the
position now in the positions as healthy
has been making my lifetime and so I
think you gotta get creative to look at
where he might go and that's why like
you mentioned the Patriots like well
what about those Chargers what about the
Giants what about the Steelers like
could it be a team that's got an older
cornerback who needs to think creatively
because they're not tracking high enough
to find that quarterback successor so
you know a Chargers really like fast you
be going back that way you know right I
just I look at the I look at what the
market would be for Rosen and I think
you know it would be it would
necessitate the cardinal singing a
little creatively on where they want to
go with it and then maybe some team
singing creatively not just about 2019
but about 20 21 and 2022 you know on
down the line and you successor to a guy
who's been in place there for a long
time senior writer for the mm QB Albert
Brewer joining us from the Cuyler Murray
Invitational better known as the NFL
Scouting Combine Alberto your Ohio State
guy so we can finally start to hear some
Nick bolsa news right I mean Nick Bose
has kind of been away from everything
since that game against TCU or than a
year he hurts his I had a abdominal
muscle tear or pull and he's out now
he's just training for the combine we
finally get a chance to see Nick Bosa
what do you expect to see from him this
weekend to kind of put him back in the
status of where he's been at for the
most part which is possibly the number
one overall pick and this year's draft
yeah well I thought your dad earlier in
the weekend you know dad said he's been
a hundred percent for about about eight
weeks and really focus on is training
and
right now might be further along
physically than he was before he got
hurt and if you watch the first three
games a year and he's five that far in
the country the first three games of
year and so I think you expect him to
put on a show here and what you've
always heard is maybe not quite as long
and as refined as jelly was coming out
um but he still I mean like he's a
student of Larry Johnson at Ohio State
they're really good ants
he's slippery get explosive and he's
always heard about him is he's just a
little bit more of a powerful athlete
than his dad a ways and so he's gonna do
everything here in India really see
plants ooh and so you would expect that
maybe that shows up in some of the
numbers but he's not caught up yeah we
always know Ohio State's gonna have a
couple guys especially in that top half
of the draft and where Denzel wore last
year a Pro Bowler in his first year
drafted as high as he did from Ohio
State but speaking of that school in
general and I'm not just giving you
shout out to your alma mater but no
one's talking to Wayne Haskins just like
Tyler Murray has stolen the show but
yeah is Dwayne Haskins still the top
quarterback on the board or has now
Kyler Murray with the way that he
weighed his height is he now starting to
push up past Dewayne Haskins you know
it's just it's one hand you get the
explosive athlete he's smaller on the
other hand you got the guy who's got the
prototypical quarterback bills right who
is nearly as athletic as Murray but is
very very evolved as a quarterback
especially for a guy who's only had 14
college starts and a guy's got better
over the course of the year and so I
think the biggest questions with Wayne
have to do with if you're gonna get
better at avoiding the rush if you're
gonna become a little bit more sudden in
the pocket get better and get a little
bit more explosive than the way that he
moves around because everything else is
there like you know he's got
you know great head to the game you saw
him grow over the course of years you
know taking an applying coaching and you
know you saw a guy go deep into
progressions and could use the full
field and so you know I think if you're
looking for a more traditional
quarterback over someone like Colin
Murray then you probably have asked in
raises the best guy in the draft a
couple more minutes here with Albert
bream QB senior writer and Albert look
one of the questions now has been
brought up is you know you have this
quote unquote non tampering tempering
period I don't know B we know the
combine all the agents are out there so
all the teams are out there as well do
you see any solutions possibly to a
Antonio Brown the the Pittsburgh
Steelers like what what else is being
talked about out there at the combine in
terms of a guy like Antonio Brown on the
move
well there's always lots of guys that
are gonna be discussed right I got you
know as far as trades go here and as you
know some I usually call the dance floor
and so you know I think one thing is a
little different this year that you
think there's at least potential for
some big-name guys to get moves just
because the way the leaves change the
last couple years and really the teams
like Eagles Moran's have had training
and so you know I mean you guys are
gonna get moved
but like you look it you know it's not
like the receiver position that you
mentioned right so the back class that
doesn't have like there's not here
number one or season draft class there's
dense but there may not be a great
receiver in the draft class if you look
at the free agents
you know Randall Cobb and Golden Tate
older guys and then you have a
complimentary piece the guys like
Jameson clatter and Colt Beasley and
Adam up they so if you're a team that's
looking for a big time number-one
receiver you know do you call the South
in 2008 jump to the contract thing do
you call those Bengals about 88 green
because of the coaching change you
called about the Giants about Odell
Beckham you know I think those are the
sorts of things that we're going to see
now
and what's going to be interesting is
whether or not the teams on the other
side of that are willing to move those
guys but I think we're in the past you
know the positive kind of bearded driven
by okay like let's find someone who's on
the out here on the out there you know
now I think those phone calls most
conversations are happening with guys
that are at the top of fosters just
because other teams have had some
success building their teams that way
and you know again it's gonna be it's
gonna be interesting to see whether or
not any of those guys to actually get
moved I expect those phone calls no
conversation path well I'll have my eyes
glued to the television this weekend yes
I will be watching the combine and I'll
be following those tweets of one Alber
Breer always appreciate the time Albert
Decker the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience